the president of kenya uhuru kenyatta is
visiting london this week saw the prime
minister yesterday and he's told sky
news
that developed countries are still not
doing enough to help vaccinate
the people of africa against covet 19.
that is in spite of the uk promising
just this week to send his country
817 000 doses of vaccine
he's uh in london to co-host a summit on
global education
alongside the prime minister boris
johnson and spoke to
sky's kimberly leonard she began by
asking whether the uk
has the moral authority to be asking
others to fund foreign aid
without a doubt the stoppage has left
the gap
now if we're going to say we're going to
look at different types of partnerships
that will fill this gap i think there
was need then to have
some kind of precaution so that
we don't have this this this gap in
between
one model as opposed to another and this
is something that we're continuing to
discuss with the british government this
is something
we are continually uh saying look
we want to partner with you we we want
to
to engage on on a different model that
also allows greater self-sufficiency and
helps
create that deepen self-sufficiency
but you know it's that transition period
that we all need to be quite careful
about another criticism is that they
just haven't been transparent
in the aid cuts that they've said listen
we're cutting the percentage
but they haven't been telling these aid
agencies you know exactly how much
they're going to cut their funding by i
mean have you had any word
on how much funding is going to be cut
to kenya
we're not 100 sure what that is but we
can say that certain
specific programs have already been
affected some
some health programs that we've been
working on together
have been affected some education
programs that we've been working on
have also equally been been affected and
that's why i'm saying
we are looking towards continually
engaging them and saying look
we we are not just we it's everybody who
has been
uh a beneficiary of of of that
assistance
you know we need to go through this
transition as we
looking for new models of how
we are going to be working together
going into the future let's talk about
covert it's been obviously a very
difficult 18 months
um specifically um let's start with
vaccines obviously this announcement 817
000 vaccines being sent out reuters
um gave these figures they said during
the last week reported
kenya averaged about 17 306 doses
administered each day
at that rate it will take a further 1
1440 days
to administer enough doses for another
10 of the population
how does that make you feel when the
head of your vaccine task force says
we have the money we have the money to
buy the vaccines
but we can't get them because they've
been reserved by the rich nation we
and i have been very clear on this one
of the things that
really has shown how unequal
this world is has been the kind of
vaccine nationalism
that we have seen where
we have and i've stated this openly and
severally
worked together you know when they were
doing clinical trials
when they were doing the research into
some of these vaccines
and then all of a sudden we find
ourselves
unable to access those same vaccines
and this is not just kenya it is
basically
the entire developing world and i think
this is something that
really really needs to be looked at
because
the fact of the matter is nobody not
here in the uk
not in the united states not in germany
nobody is going to be safe until
everybody's safe
and we need to be able to come up with
a way of ensuring that there is going to
be
equity in the distribution of these
vaccines and this is something we on the
african continent we in kenya
are very perturbed about and that is why
we're saying we need to now be able to
focus
on our own production
you can't simply say you're not going to
remove the the the intellectual property
but yet at the same time here we are
ready to pay you for the vaccine
and then you say you're not able to
deliver so is that what you're doing
really it really you can't say no to
this and so then what happens
where do we get these vaccines from how
are we able to protect our populations
so then what do you say to these nations
where you've got okay 800
000 odd from the uk they're pledging
that astrazeneca right
what do you say to them when they're
saying okay we're going to give booster
jabs to people we have
music festivals when people can walk in
and get vaccines and yet
in your own country you have health
workers who are unvaccinated
not only with the uk this is this is a
battle we actually have
with the entire developing world where
we know there are some countries
that have vaccinated well over 40 50
percent
of their adult population are now
vaccinating even teenagers
and on top of that have surpluses 40
50 million doses but are still not ready
to share that with the rest of the world
that is is is is is is the height like i
said
of a nationalism that really has to be
dealt with and this is something
we are fighting and we're going to fight
day and night until we ensure
that there is equity in the provision of
these